you
good morning Jace comes so you already
know my name
I've never seen it this big can someone
take a picture of it for me I'll be
grateful okay
today I'd like to share with you some of
the questions I was asking myself about
numbers in JavaScript because even
Brendan Eich yesterday at least keynote
told us that the numbers are not really
perfect currently that's why all these
new types of numbers are being
introduced for future versions but today
I like to focus on what currently we
have in JavaScript in terms of numbers
because if you ever tried to do some
computations on decimal fractions or
large integers in JavaScript you
probably noticed that they are not
really precise and may lead to some
quite unexpected results let me give you
some examples of that if we try to add
zero point one to zero points to you
would expect it will be equal to zero
point three but it's not what it's
actually equal to it's a number very
close to zero point three on the other
hand if you take quite a large integer
like for example this one and you try to
add one to it you will get exactly the
same number but if you add 2 to it you
get the result as expected but it's not
only about inaccurate results of some
computations there are many different
weird things about the numbers in
JavaScript like this in famous not a
number value so not a number is a value
you will get if you try to turn into
Java in to a number something that is
not
so let's try something like this but if
you try to check the type of not a
number it will tell you it's a number
and every time I stumbled upon something
like this happening Gong I was asking
myself why does it happen because there
has to be a reason right things like
that don't happen without the reason at
least in most cases and if you're asking
yourself a question about JavaScript
there is one sure place to look for the
answer
the ACMA script standard but all the
standard says about the numbers is that
they are represented by the double
precision 64-bit format I Triple E 754
binary floating-point arithmetic
actually yeah it's just a little bit
more than that but nothing about how the
numbers are represented in the memory
how the calculations are done so I had
to look the further but it turns out
that javascript is not the first
language that uses this standard there
are many others if you try for example
Python we have exactly the same problems
in here
something more modern like Ruby nope
and of course Java actually I had to
read write a class to add these two
numbers in Java anyway it turns out that
we have these kind of numbers in
JavaScript because they were in Java at
the first place right so I was still
asking myself why does it happen what is
wrong with this representation of the
numbers that we have such imprecise
results and the first step I wanted to
make was to see how a given number looks
like in this binary representation I
wanted to see every single bit of this
64 bit representation
unfortunately in JavaScript we don't
really have easy direct access to bits
in memory but with a little help from my
friends typed our eyes I was able to
create myself a little utility function
so now we can turn any number let's say
our 0.3 and see how it looks in its
binary representation so these are all
64 bits of binary representation of
number 0.3 in this double precision
floating point so let's compare it to
result of the computation of 0.1 plus
0.2 it's almost the same but if you look
at the last three bits on the right side
you will see that there is a little
difference there and yeah we can take
any number we want like I don't know
2013 0 9 and see how it looks like but
looking at these zeros and ones doesn't
really give us any kind of understanding
what is going on there how these numbers
are computed fortunately because this
standard is used in many languages there
are quite a few resources online that
tell us how does the standard work I
gathered a couple of these here but
unfortunately they are full of crazy
equations and operations on binary
numbers and it took me quite a few long
evenings a lot of paper to get my head
around how it really works so here I am
to save you the trouble and hopefully
after this talk you will actually be
able to understand this Wikipedia page
so let's see how this representation
works so as I already mentioned a couple
of times we have 64 bits to represent
our number and they can be divided into
three parts there is one bit for a sign
is this guy in here it tells us if the
number is positive or negative negative
there is this big chunk on the right 52
bits actually it's 53 because one of
them is hidden I will talk about this
guy later this part is called
significant if you are American English
user you probably call it mantissa
sometimes it's referred as
fraction but basically this 52 bits are
representing the binary digits of our
number and some of them are used to
represent the integer part of our number
and the others are for the fraction and
I use this this point in here to show
where this split happens so this bits on
the left of this point are used to
represent the integer part and the rest
is for the fraction and the remaining 11
bits is the exponent and the exponent is
kind of a multiplier that is used to
scale the value given by the significant
to give us the final value of our number
and I'm pretty sure it's quite confusing
at this point so let me give you a
little bit of analogy I hope that you've
at least at some point of your life seen
a number written like this it's so
called exponential or scientific
notation so in this notation we also
have a number divided into two parts
this is there is this part it represents
the significant digits of our numbers so
all the digits we want to have in our
number and it's also called significant
and we compute number by multiplying it
times 10 to the power of the exponent so
the exponent is kind of a scaling factor
so the bigger the exponent gets the
bigger our number will be and the
smaller the exponent gets the smaller
value of our number will have and we can
look at this exponent as kind of
defining the position of the point in
our representation because when the
exponent gets higher the point kind of
moves to the right and makes this number
bigger and when the exponent gets
smaller it kind of moves the point to
the left making the numbers smaller and
smaller and actually the roles of
significant and exponent in this binary
notation for the floating point numbers
are exactly the same so let's get back
to it and see how it works and more
details so design bit there is not much
to say about this guy if its value is
zero the number is positive because it's
counted as the power of minus one and if
we turn it to one our number becomes
negative simple as that
exponent is a little bit more
interesting so we have eleven bits to
represent the exponent and the exponent
that is an integer value so we can
represent the number from zero to 2047
but we would actually want exponent to
have negative and positive values so
what is actually used in so called
offset binary notation so we take the
number computed from the powers of two
of the from the bits of exponent this
one and we subtract 1023 from it it's
exactly the health of the range so when
our value computed from the exponent
bits gets exactly to this point of 1022
three our exponent will be zero and when
it gets lower the exponent will be
negative when it's higher the exponent
will be positive and this number the
value for the exponent is actually
defining the position of this point in
the significant so it defines how many
bits we have for the integer part of the
number and how many are left for the
fraction part so the bigger our exponent
gets the more bits we have for the
integer part and the bigger our integer
value gets the smaller exponent is the
point will move to the left making
giving us less bits for the integer part
and actually that's why it's called the
floating point because the position of
the point is depends on the value of the
exponent so now let's have a look at the
most important part the significant as I
told you already we have 52 bits these
are these red ones and here this first
guy is this hidden
we can save him here yeah and we can
stick him because we don't actually
control its value its value is always
assumed to be one so that's why we don't
have to put them into 64 bits because we
can't change it to zero so to explain
you how this significant works let's
start with something simple like number
one so for number one our exponent is
zero
so it puts our point in here so we have
one bit on the left hand side this one
bit representing our integer part and it
represents two to the power of zero so
it's one but we have only one bit for
the integer we can't represent any
bigger number so if we try to represent
the number two we have to move the point
to the right by changing the exponent so
now we have two bits for the integer
part this first bit is representing 2 to
the power of 1 at this point so it gives
us 2 and the other one is representing 2
to the power of 0 so we can represent
also number 3 but again we just used our
2 bits in the integer part so to
represent number 4 we have to again move
the point to the right by changing the
exponent so now we have oops sorry
yeah I was at for ideas so now we have
three bits for the integer part the
first one represents two to the power of
two the last one represents two to the
power of zero so the bigger number we
want to represent in terms of the
integer value the more bits we will need
for the integer part now let's see how
the fraction part works the first bit
after the point represents two to the
power of minus one so it gives us 1/2 to
the power of one so it gives us a half
so by changing this first bit after the
point we can represent 0.5 fraction the
next one is representing 2 to the power
of minus 2 so it gives us a quarter next
one is 2 to the power of minus 3
it's 1/8 and so on and so on every
single bit and the fraction part
represents smaller and smaller fraction
based on the inverse power of 2 so what
it tells us is that we can only build
the fraction of our number by adding up
these inverted powers of 2 and
unfortunately not all of decimal
fractions can be represented this way so
if we take our zero point one example we
can see that to form zero point one we
are adding smaller and smaller powers of
two
but actually they will never add up to
exactly zero point one value so this
value is already stored in this
representation with a little bit of
error and these errors add up when we do
some computations on these numbers and
at some point they they show up so the
limit of this representation in terms of
accuracy of the fractions is based on
two factors first factor is that we are
building our fraction from the inverse
power of Paris of two and the other
factor is that we actually have quite
limited 52 bits of significant we can't
represent the smaller values what is
even more important is that
the bigger number we get in terms of the
integer value so when we need more and
more bits for the integer part the less
bits we have left for the fraction part
so when we move the point right to the
end of this representation let's see to
this point for such a large integer
value we have only one bit left for the
fraction part so we can only represent
the house
we can't represent any other fraction
for such a large numbers so what happens
if we move the point even more to the
right if the exponent is equal to 52 we
have all the bits of the significant
used for the integer value there is no
bit left for the fraction part so from
this point we can only represent
integers value so the biggest integer
value that actually fits into this
significant is this one we've used all
the bits in the significant part to
represent this number now what would
happen if we try to represent the bigger
number let's see let's change that what
happens is kind of what we expected we
moved the point to the right to make a
more space for the integer part so we
have right now 53 bits for the integer
part but actually there is no bit left
there so how the number is computed so
what happens is that it's assumed that
all these bits that are missing are
zeros so this number is actually
accurately represented because this last
bit is assumed to be zero but what would
happen if we try to add one to it again
we can't because we can't change the
value of this last bit because we don't
control it it's it's always zero so the
last bit we actually control is this one
and it represents two to the power of
one so we can only add two to this
number so so from this point when the
exponent is equal to 53 we can
only represent every second integer
until we get to this point and again to
represent the bigger number we again
have to add 2 to it we will move point
to the right so right now we have 2 bits
that are assumed to be 0 so the last
value the last bit of we control is
representing 2 to the power of 2 so it's
4 so we can represent only every 4th
integer for exponent equal to 54 so the
bigger the exponent gets the bigger gaps
we will have between the integers values
we can represent so actually starting
from this exponent 52 we already have
gaps between the numbers so actually any
operations on on such a large integers
will have some error and similar thing
happens on the other side of the
significant if we make it smaller when
we have the exponent value of minus 1 so
our point is right before the hidden bit
this hidden bit represents 1/2 and every
other bit in the significant represents
smaller and smaller powers of 2 and when
we move the point the left we are
getting some missing bits assumes to be
zeros our first bit insignificant
represents smaller and smaller power of
2 so we are getting closer and closer to
0 but when we have this bit the hidden
bit assumed to be 1 it always represents
some power of 2 it can be very small but
there will be always some value in here
all right so we will never be able to
represent number 0 because we'll always
have some value given by this bit
fortunately this representation has a
section for death so when our exponent
gets his lowest possible value so when
the all bits of the exponent are zero so
our exponent is minus 1023 the hidden
bits also turns to zero so this way we
can represent zero as all the bits being
zero and we can of course change some
bits and significant to represent
numbers very close to zero they are
called sub normal values because of this
hidden bit being 0 but you may remember
this sign guy in here and I told you
that we can use it to change the sign of
any number represented in this
representation so what would happen if
we change the sign of 0 yeah we will get
minus 0 actually the floating point
representation defines two zeros
positive and negative one in JavaScript
it's not very easy to notice this
negative zero because there are only
certain operations that return it like
dividing by minus infinity but it's
there and the difference between
negative 0 and positive 0 can be
actually detected so we've seen what
happens when the exponent is again when
the exponent is at its lowest value so
now let's see the other side of the
extreme when we have all the bits of the
exponent set to 1 for the highest
exponent value this is the value
reserved for the Infinity positive or
negative infinity so that's how the
Infinity looks like all the exponent
bits set to 1 and all the significant
bits set to 0 and what will happen if we
try to change this significant bits to
Banke we get to now and it's not because
there is some error actually floating
point representation defines not a
number value so if all the exponent bits
are set to 1 and any bit in the
significant is set to 1 it's not a
number value so it kind of explains why
not a number type is a number because
not a number is a value defined by the
floating point representation it's
defined by 64 bits like any other number
actually this we have 52 bits in
significance so there are quite many not
a number values defined in this
representation fortunately to us Java
Script simplifies it to only one not a
number yeah but let's get maybe back to
numbers and summarize it what we already
heard here so for any given number we
can compute its value by computing the
values of the significant bits with the
position of the point based on the value
from the exponent and design defining a
design of our number but as I told you
at the very beginning we can treat the
exponent as kind of a multiplier so if
we take it out of this parenthesis and
treat it as a multiplier we start to
compute the significant value always
starting with two to the power of zero
it's the value given by this hidden bit
so we can always set it to 1 because you
know 2 to the power of 0 is 1
so that's the one given by the hidden
bit and here we have the value computed
for the exponent and this way we kind of
reverse engineered the equation for
how the numbers are computed in double
floating-point representation and that's
the equation you can find in similar
fashion on this Wikipedia page so I know
it was quite a hardcore topic for a
Sunday morning after the great party but
I hope that I have given you at least a
little bit of understanding how numbers
in JavaScript work and why we have all
these problems we've done and hopefully
after this talk we can all think about
ourselves as those who understand binary
and maybe next time you stumble upon
some weird behavior with numbers or with
JavaScript and you will ask yourself why
because answers and reasons are out
there waiting for us to find them so be
curious because there is hell a lot of
interesting things you can learn and
sometimes quite unexpected answers you
can get so that was all I had for you
you can follow me on Twitter
do any questions is there anything left
that you didn't want to know about
numbers that you somehow wanna know now
yes sorry can you keep your hand up I
there we go sorry my Tracking's not so
good right I mean from some cloud thanks
for the talk was great I just want to
add something if you would want to work
with big numbers you can actually use
libraries for that which are called big
naam libraries these exist in most
languages and yeah I found myself in a
situation won't yeah thanks
yeah that's true I was just focusing on
the numbers representation how they're
in this floating point right okay thank
you so much Bartok
you